I think you've said before that being
fired in Hollywood is a rite of passage
and it's not it's not the end of the
road it's actually great you're part of
the club now yes I think like when we
think of ego so when I wrote my book
change your story change your life it
was all based on that life moment on the
life unexpected life moment of my
pursuit taking a turn and being in
interrupted mid process and I would say
that I thought in the choice that I made
that led to my contract not being picked
up that I was responding from my spirit
but I recognized through the writing
process in the therapeutic process of
healing that I wasn't responding from my
spirit because my spirit had been
depleted because the ego had taken over
in the pursuit of being an executive and
so I think that many people who get
fired the ego is the first response we
think oh my god you know what are people
going to think am I ever going to be
able to get a job again is everything
that I learned going to become obsolete
because someone didn't like me or
someone chose not to see me does it all
mean nothing and and that is the ego
getting caught up in the action of being
fired versus recognizing that being
fired has the advantage of showing us
what didn't work and pushing us into a
direction of what could work and I want
to say for writers being fired is
absolutely a rite of passage like you
are going to have countless situations
where your personality may not mesh with
the showrunners personality where your
story
skills may not be in alignment with the
concept of the show none of that means
that you are a bad person or you are a
bad writer all it means is you weren't a
fit for that situation and that there is
something better that is gonna be more
in alignment with your skills in your
personality type that is going to serve
you in a stronger way so it's owning it
like I've I've had I have one writer
who's a close friend of mine who is at
the top of his game and beloved in this
town and he has admitted I've had him
speak at events of mine and I'll never
forget one event where he admitted that
he had been fired from almost every job
he had ever had and it was so empowering
for me to hear him say this because what
it said to me was I know I have talent
because I wouldn't be here if I didn't
and it doesn't mean that I haven't had
struggles along the way and because I
have applied the tools and healed from
every one of these I continue to propel
myself forward I see so much of why
someone does well at an organization a
lot almost always to do with the culture
and are you a fit yes nothing to do with
sometimes the skill set yes see it has
to do with to the rest of people like
the person yeah are you in in an
alignment with the values there if
someone comes from an environment of
family where success is regarded and the
title and doing well and where are you
this year is so important how do they
handle that let's suppose they they have
to go to a family gathering and they've
been fired they haven't told their
family yeah and well so what's your in
LA what are you doing you know you're
all around the dinner table it's
Thanksgiving whatever what what do you
tell that person do they tell them I
mean I guess it's sort of a personal oh
I always think I think my
worldview in life is lead with the why
lead with and what I mean by that is the
why explains why we want what we want
and the why often involves the wound in
the process and that's how we engage and
we find our audience so if your parents
truly believe that and many parents
doubt it there I work with an endless
amount of writers who tell me that their
parents will give them so much time or
their wife will give them so much time
to do this pursuit and then it has it so
I think it's more difficult for those
people with the recognition that there's
a ticking time clock to be honest when
they go through a fall but I I think I
encourage those people to engage because
this is what we have to recognize now
let's talk about Obama's speech the
other night which I had personally
thought was probably one of the best
presidential speeches I've ever heard in
the reason that I connected to it was
humility was the recognition of where he
failed and and to me the message that
that sends out is the failure should not
be what we're looking at the trying and
the attempt to achieve should be what is
making us move forward we should always
be taking actions forward we should
always recognize that there are going to
be monumental obstacles that are going
to get in our way and we should never
let that defeat us do you find though
people that have come from more of a
drill sergeant type upbringing as I've
known certain people I haven't
personally had that pressure but I've
known other people that and
their title and what they do is
incredibly important to the family and
if they're not that they they almost
feel like they can't do anything
creative they've got to have this like
label so have you seen that in some of
the writing and some of the people that
you've worked with and how do you kind
of ease up on them and or not that it's
you doing it but kind of have them ease
up on themselves because they have that
little thing in them that's driving them
I would say that the action that a
writer can take that does not have
familial support or does have people who
doubt their pursuit I would say the the
strongest action they can take is
bringing that to the page interesting
because that is the hero's journey that
is the recognition that they're going to
be internal and external obstacles to
where we want to go and our you know I
think everything that builds character
in life and in story is our emotional
response to what happens to us
you